[Music]
I'm in the storage room
we need an elevator ah this is a lot his
new room I love this you did a great job
what do you mean you didn't do it you
know time to rush you Gina did this yes
he painted he made her a chalkboard wall
is that a mini-fridge yeah there's a
mini-fridge in her bedroom
really June bubble gum popcorn you
really think that's a good idea I mean
he thought it would be cool when God
knows is more than her father has ever
done for her well that's fantastic I
love it but I'm worried that maybe now
she's gonna get super attached to him
and what happens if it doesn't work I
mean you really haven't known in that
long
okay I mean we moved in together quickly
Gene's always been reckless in her
relationships and I've picked up the
pieces before when it's all falling
apart so can we just slow this roll down
I mean tons gonna tail if Gina's gonna
be a good guy or not Gina came into our
life when we needed someone to say okay
men aren't that bad the book was sugar
bear I know he's even a great father to
Ilana oh my god and we say stepfather so
that there's never an issue with that
okay who cares I really I really wish to
you know could be a real father
what is your problem would you know
living with my sister in the house with
my nieces you've kept him hidden away
scrolled away and no one knows who he is
oh my god you firm had to be happy for
me period because he's not going
anywhere
we are happy I love him I care about him
he can be the father figure of a lot of
and pumpkin and he's someone that I want
to wake up to every day and he's going
to be my husband one day oh my god I
can't believe he just had a husband
[Music]